as the clock ticks down to midnight on
new year's eve what better way to
celebrate the year that was than through
the app that was 2021 yep we're talking
tick-tock i love it from taylor swift to
britney spears to jason derulo to
literally keeping up with the
kardashians these are the must-see tick
tocks from 2021. let's kick things off
with jason derulo the unofficial king of
the app you gonna give us some tick tock
dances or what uh savage love
[Music]
somebody did somebody break your heart
when turning himself blue and shrinking
to performing a dance number with horror
villains pennywise freddy krueger
ghostface and more jason never holds
back
[Music]
put your head on my shoulder
my eyes up here
from the king of tick tock to the
princess of pop it's britney [ __ ]
britney won her freedom back in court
and won over our hearts on tick tock
with her unconventional posts like this
one from march paying tribute to her
fiance sam askari
[Music]
and from one pop star to another it's
just a wonderful new time for us hilary
duff had some fun at her own expense
taking part in the with love choreo
challenge after this old dance routine
went viral on the app
[Music]
another disney alum selena gomez also
loves posting videos on tick tock with
her little sister gracie
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think my sister overthinks
anything and that's what i love about
her she enjoys it she's excited about
life she also goes solo on the app lip
syncing to songs
and shares funny moments with friends
hello
dude
then there's justin bieber the ghost
singer teamed up with coyla rae for the
twin-em challenge after her single
became the unofficial anthem of the app
[Music]
no no friends
alicia silverstone totally won tik tok
this year with her clueless reenactments
ah
you might remember this scene from the
classic movie cher get in here what's up
daddy what the hell is that a dress says
who calvin klein it looks like underwear
well in alicia's 2021 update her son
bear steps in for the part of cher's dad
jaya get in here what's up daddy what
the hell is that
a dress
says who calvin klein it looks like
underwear alicia i need to give you
major props because your tick tock game
is so strong watching you do these
reenactments of iconic clueless scenes
has been so much fun with your son how
do those moments come about i was forced
into it
um well we get them so quickly the one
that we did the very first tic-tac that
i did my son had been talking about
hip-hop for a long time but he uh
that i needed to and i kept saying no no
no no and finally i gave in and thought
it would be really fun
[Music]
next up paris hilton who actually used
the app to play gossip cop debunking
this infamous pick i never wore that
shirt
this was completely photoshopped
everyone thinks it's real
but that's not the truth and while paris
might have been shutting down lavish
lifestyle talk will smith was showing
off with this epic moment from his trip
to dubai
[Music]
deep dive dubai i'm about to go down
deepest pool on earth
[Music]
you scared me for a second now onto a
star who definitely knows the true
meaning of being deep former blues clues
host steve burns and it just it's just
so amazing right he joined the app in
september after resurfacing for the
beloved children's show's 25th
anniversary hi out there it's me steve i
don't
know how to use tick tock at all
okay enough of getting in our feelings
next up on our list of favorite celeb
tick tocks from 2021 is lizzo dressing
up as baby yoda for halloween watch as
she hits the streets of hollywood
[Music]
another celeb who knows how to let loose
is taylor swift who resurrected drunk
taylor for this instantly iconic moment
i've had
too much to drink tomorrow
and it wouldn't be a true best celeb
tick tocks of 2021 if we didn't end with
the kardashians i'm so excited kourtney
kardashian and daughter penelope disick
took tick-tock by storm with their
mother-daughter videos
oh wait no way you're kidding he didn't
just say what i think he did did he and
dr dre said
idiots dr dre is dead he's locked in my
basement and following in their
footsteps kim kardashian and north west
you know what we're not really
competitive kim k and northie jump in
the mix with their super cute mommy and
me tick tocks like lip syncing to adele
[Music]
north was even able to convince her mom
to dance a little whatever she wants to
do when she is old enough she can do
holy spirit activate
oh on
activate holy spirit activate activate
activate